hi I'm the umbrella president grease
group I just moderate the session on
cheap with low risks and in Asia and the
focus really was on the changing nature
of economics and security ties that are
driving cohesion and driving countries
apart across Asia for the last several
decades the United States and the West
was really driving both economic
integration as well as providing
security across the region that's still
true and security for our terms for many
countries but it's absolutely not true
for economics and a big question that
was asked by the camels to what extent
there's just the lag that will bring
security ties ultimately more regional
within Asia or whether there's going to
be two systems that will just uneasily
parallel in either way there's going to
be some rebalancing and I think a lot of
books on the panel were concerned about
that there was general constrained
Jewish China tensions are increasing
even the Minister of Foreign Affairs in
Indonesia said he didn't believe they
were getting better and given how
oriented the notations are towards
hedging that's a fairly significant non
statement beyond that there's a general
feeling global architecture is breaking
down as it is you're seeing more
bilateral relationships become much more
important on the economic front on the
security front and the creation
potentially of new multilateral
architecture in Asia I would still ant
nation faces an overall course economic
wealth is growing dramatically in Asia
and prosperity means that you don't have
to worry the same way about Jasmine
revolutions that you do with the Middle
East but despite that prosperity is a
view that there's more volatility to
your politically in Israel and there has
been a very long time thanks very much